So it's 9 o'clock on the West Coast.
So good morning, everyone, and good afternoon
to those who are joining us from the East
Coast.
I'm Alex Bui.
I'm the co-director of the BD2K Centers Coordination
Center.
So we're wrapping up section two of our Data
Science Center, which to remind you has been
an overview of data representation issues.
We've covered a spectrum of different topics,
starting with databases and data warehousing
challenges, through to issues related to data
wrangling and exploration.
And today we're going to hear about natural
language processing, or NLP, from Dr. Noemie
Elhadad of Columbia University.
And for any of you who have had to deal with
either unstructured clinical reports or other
types of data, such as biomedical literature,
you can already appreciate many of the issues
of trying to get a computer to understand
a textual document.
NLP has been and continues to be an active
area of research, particularly in regards
to the biomedical space.
So it's my pleasure to introduce Dr. Elhadad.
She is an associate professor of biomedical
informatics at Columbia.
And as a data scientist, her efforts focus
on the development of techniques, smart clinicians,
patients, and health researchers in the information
workflows by automatically extracting and
making accessible information from large clinical
datasets.
Two particular areas of interest in her research
include computational approaches that infer
models of health phenomena and that account
for the specific biases seen in large health
datasets and the translation of these models
into actionable knowledge and applications.
Dr. Elhadah, we're delighted to have you with
us this morning.
And so without further ado, let's get started.
The floor is yours.
Great.
Thank you, Alex.
Hi everyone.
So I'm going to be talking to you about natural
language processing and NLP in health in particular.
And the way I think I'm going to structure
this lecture is into four topics.
And I'm going to spend most of my time on
actually the first two topics.
The first one is to kind of give you an overview
of the applications of natural language processing
in health and health care.
It's a very active field of research for core
NLP methods, but for the sake of this audience
here, I think it's interesting to think about
all the different ways in which texts and
semi-structured texts can be leveraged for
advancing knowledge of biomedical sources
or for helping clinicians in their daily care
of patients.
I am then going to be spending quite some
time on talking with you through some examples
of why computing language is difficult, and
I'll give you an example both in the general
and in the health domain, too.
And then I'll move on to some approaches in
health natural language processing.
There's been a shift in
computing approaches, and so it's interesting
to kind of give an overview of those.
And I'll conclude with the current developments
in both domain-generic NLP and health NLP
research.
So let me just start by saying something that
might be obvious to you by now as human beings,
which is that language is primitive.
As women, when we talk to each other, we use
language in written and not written form,
and the big revolution for us in the computing
world is that there is more and more of such
instances of written text available to us.
And so this is an example of a J-identified
clinical note.
And the things to notice here which are going
to become a themes is that it's English, but
it's not your typical English, right?
So like there's a lot of abbreviations like
HPI, which means history of present illness,
and so if I read, if I were to read this first
sentence, I would say 77-year-old male, with
history of hypertension, coronary artery disease,
status post coronary artery bypass left, 1988,
meaning that happened in 1988.
And so you can already kind of think about
the challenges that we have here, right?
We are trying to maybe understand or extract
some information from these type of texts,
and we have to somehow be able to encode or
to reason about the fact that this note is
about a male patient of that particular age,
at the time the note was written, and some
procedures were given to the patient, like
the CABG, and we actually didn't have timing
for these procedures, but there are also information
about medications, symptoms, disorders, et
cetera, et cetera.
Another really important source of pretext
for people who do NLP is the literature, the
scientific literature.
And here maybe the language is more structured,
but it's still a very specific genre of text.
And there are some things that we can leverage.
We know that scientific articles have some
structure to them, their backgrounds, methods,
results, conclusions, et cetera.
But they also have slightly complex sentences
from a syntactic standpoint.
And so if we want to be able to understand
what type of information is being conveyed
in these articles and do so at scale across
many articles, then we need to probably be
able to parse these sentences accurately.
Health news are becoming an important source
of knowledge and trends in health and other
domains as well.
I'm sure you know outside of health, there's
all these interesting new things happening
with fake news, for example.
So how do we detect that something is a fake
news?
How do we detect that vitamin B12 is indeed
correlated with higher cancer risk?
You could think of the health news as a way
to disseminate information that comes with
science, but with a very biased slant.
And interestingly, from an NLP standpoint,
we see yet a different style of language.
And finally another type of text that is of
interest to natural language processing people
is all the information that patients and health
consumers are exchanging on the social web.
So this is an example from a publicly available
breast cancer community.
And I like this example because it kind of
describes to us in a very clear fashion what
some of our issues are going to be if we want
to, if we want to parse this type of text.
And so this sounds like a very exciting--
this is a thread.
ChainsawZ is the first person writing, and
she's very happy.
She said about someone else that she's glad
you found reggie but I hope you don't consume
for the twoto-one NED or NED.
And it sounds like it's not about cancer.
It actually is about breast cancer, but what
happens here is a common phenomenon in online
communities, where the community is coming
up with their own abbreviations and nearly
their own register of language.
And so in fact "reggie" is regression of tumor,
and NED or NED is "no evidence of disease."
And so this is referring to the fact that
someone has regression of her tumor and everyone
is very happy.
There's a lot of positive sentiment, which
can be easily identified automatically.
But we also would love to be able to automatically
identify that this person we're talking about
had a regression in her tumor.
So what are some of the applications that
have been heavily using NLP?
One that is a classic application and a very
robust one by no and still some time for interesting
reason is becoming yet again a new question
is automated coding of clinical notes.
So the task here is I have a clinical note,
typically a discharge summary.
And on the other hand, I have a very large
taxonomy of diagnosis codes, or ICD-9 codes,
and I would like to be able to automatically
say what are the most, say, eight or 10 or
15 likely codes that can help me bill for
a visit or that can help me represent what
this note is about.
So from a computing standpoint, the difficulty
here is twofold.
On one hand, we have free text, and the second
difficulty is that it's not a simple text
categorization task because it's multilevel
classification.
That universe of labels is really, really
wide.
So ICD-9 codes, there's about 15,000 of them.
And I'm sure you guys know, we actually in
the United States have moved to ICD-10 coding,
where now we're talking about 65,000-plus
codes.
So again from a computing standpoint, how
do we train algorithms to recognize what are
the most likely codes is an interesting question.
In a very classical question of NLP, where
NLP has been used again in the clinical world,
is one of cohort detection.
And I know you have had a lecture on information
retrievals, so I'm not going to go too much
into it, but it's an important one.
By the way, I gave examples of articles that
I think represent very well what the NLP challenges
are and what the tasks or methods are.
And so you're welcome to go and look at them,
but they're just simple examples.
There's actually quite a lot of research on
each of those areas.
And so here again the interesting fact is
that if we want to select a cohort, say from
the electronic health records.
So if we want to identify in the electronic
health record, who are the patients who have
a particular disease?
In this example, we're talking about peripheral
arterial disease.
Then we know we could use some of the metadata
that's available to us, but we also would
probably want to use or leverage the clinical
notes.
And as a matter of fact, it turns out that
when it comes to identifying cohorts, the
NLP's often quite critical to identifying
the right population.
Clinical decision support is a traditional
example of clinical informatics, where again
NLP would be useful.
The idea
Clinical decision support is a traditional
example of clinical informatics, where again
NLP would be useful.
The idea here is to leverage information from
clinical notes within the logic of clinical
decisions support.
So if we want to have an alert that looks
at potentially dangerous drug-drug interactions
at the time of prescription, in the electronic
health record, or if we want to make sure
that we're not prescribing the drug when a
patient has a specific allergy, this type
of clinical decision support system will go
and look at the structured information or
does it make that data available in the electronic
health record?
But again, there is no guarantee that all
the information about the patient is included
in the structured part of the EHR.
And in fact, very often, old allergies or
old things kind of fall through the cracks,
and are documented in the notes, but not in
the structured part.
And so NLP here, again, is extremely helpful.
Another type of application is one of data
exploration.
And this comes from the fact that there is
so much text available to clinicians, to house
practitioners, to researchers, that we need
to help and support them in just making sense
of all the data that's available.
So this is an example of a patient's record
summarization system that we have at Columbia
University.
And it's actually deployed and used by physicians.
And the idea here is that we're taking all
of the notes longitudinally.
We have 20-plus years worth of data for each
of our patients.
And we can, through natural language processing,
identify what are the primary problems for
that patient, and on top of it, have an interactive
visualization that allows the clinicians and
EHR workers to explore and go through the
timeline of a patient.
This is another example of how NLP can be
used for data exploration.
This is in a slightly different genre of text.
We're looking at autism spectrum disorder
communities.
So these are parents of children, typically,
who are on the ASD spectrum.
And the question, again, is there is a lot
of discussions.
How do I make sense of all of these discussions?
Why would I want to do this?
Maybe I'm a public health practitioner, and
I want to look into health communication issues.
Or maybe I want to learn about how parents
are viewing certain treatments.
Or what is the awareness about particular
disorders or symptoms for patients?
And so here what we've done is, we've created
a set of named entity recognition system that
can identify terms in posts, and so on the
top right here you see an example a snippet
from a post.
And we then did so for all the posts in the
community, and built, again, a visualization
to help with exploration on top that kind
of builds a network of significantly occurring
pairs of terms.
And so in this case, we were in, again, an
autism community.
And [INAUDIBLE] is very specific to the language
and the register and the domain of autism.
But it's interesting to see in which context,
basically, that type of term is being talked
about.
This is another example of data exploration
from text that has been extremely successful
in many different areas, actually.
And this is one of topic modeling.
And so this is taken from a paper that looked
at all of the publications from Science journal,
and is trying to make sense, in a very unsupervised
fashion, about all the different topics or
themes that have been talked about in the
Science journal over 100 plus years.
So what is the challenge here?
The challenge is that we do not know in advance.
We're completely unsupervised.
We do not know in advance.
We're not making any hypotheses about what
type of themes are being discussed in these
articles.
And we want a method that can allow us to
identify what are the primary themes.
And moreover, in the case of correlated topic
models like in this example, we want to know
how these themes relate to each other.
And so we can build this type, again, of visualizations
that tells us that RNA, DNA, and that type
of cluster of words here correspond to a significant
topic or a cluster.
And moreover, it is quite relevant related
to-- meaning it occurs or it correlates often--
with a topic about sequencing and genetic
sequencing, and another one about proteins,
for example.
So the value here is that when you have a
very, very large corpus given to you, for
example, all of the articles published in
a journal, and you're trying to extract, to
understand what are the primary topics discussed
in that journal, like in this example, or
if you have a patient cohort with lots of
anatomic health-related notes related to them,
or if you have access to an online house community,
for example, prior to detecting a particular
phenomenon, maybe you want to just explore
and understand what is being talked about.
And so a lot of NLP methods rely on this type
of topic modeling for data exploration.
So another thing that you can do with this
type of topic modeling is you can then look
at how they change through time.
So again, this is from the Science journal
article, where you can look at-- these are
examples of two different topics.
And you can look at, through time, from the
earliest years of publication of the Science
journal in 1880 up to 2000 what, for example,
the mention of the term "oxygen," and what
was basically the interest, maybe, of oxygen
in the journal.
So keep in mind, we're not extracting information
here.
We're just identifying kind of salient terms
that are representative of the corpus here.
And again, it should not be interpreted as
a literal representation of the corpus, but
rather as a tool for data exploration.
And a more and more prevalent type of application
has to come with surveillance from publicly
available data sets.
This is a very active field of research.
I'm putting here in just two examples of papers,
but there are many, many more, where the authors
are anything at public social media sources,
so things like Twitter or Yelp, and trying
to identify very specific occurrences of a
condition.
In this case, the authors and the Department
of Health and [INAUDIBLE] are interested in
identifying who has had food-borne illness
after eating in a restaurant, so that they
can
go and investigate what's going on with that
restaurant.
So what are the challenges again here, from
an NLP standpoint?
Well, on the top left, you see a Yelp review.
And we want to, knowing that we're looking
at food-borne illness, we want to be able
to go and extract that someone was sick, but
not only just generally sick, but sick from
eating.
And not only that, the symptoms of foodborne
illness kind of happened after enough time
that it would kind of support the idea that
food-borne illness came from that restaurant.
So it's a complex information extraction test.
There is a bit of reasoning involved in here.
Another challenge is that, especially if we're
talking about Twitter, not all of the information
is going to be nicely contained into a single
text.
And there is going to be, maybe, conversations,
and all sorts of interesting linguistic phenomena,
such as coreferences that are going to be
needed to be taken care of to identify, for
example, like in this example on the bottom
right here, that this person indeed got sick,
and that that was a particular location where
the restaurant was the potential culprit for
the food-borne illness.
Researchers have been thinking about this
idea of info surveillance quite a lot.
This is HealthMap, which I encourage you to
go and visit.
This is work from Harvard and John Brownstein.
And if you Google HealthMap, you'll find it
right away.
And it's a very nice interactive visualization
of all the potential diseases that are being
talked about, typically on the news.
But they are incorporating other data sources
as well in here.
And so again, the same challenges come again.
How do we identify that a particular disease
is being talked about?
And moreover, in this case, what is the location
of where the patients are being notified about?
So let me switch gears and continue with my
summary of applications.
This is going back to the clinical domain.
We're interested in high throughput phenotyping.
Why do we want to do high throughput phenotyping?
We want to maybe be able to identify all conditions
that are being talked about across a large
cohort of patients.
Or maybe we want to do that [INAUDIBLE] identification,
but instead of finding methods to do so very
well for one disease at a time, maybe we want
to do it for all diseases at once.
And the reason I'm bringing up this example
is mostly because the methods are very similar
to the one of topic
modeling.
And they're interesting, because they're taking
into account not only the text, but also the
other data structure information that we have
in the electronic health records, such as
laboratory tests, medications, and diagnosis
notes.
And so we can build NLP-based methods that
kind of incorporate this additional information,
and bring better cues, basically, to identify
what are the observations that enable us to
decide that there is probably diabetes mellitus
Type 2 for a particular patient, for example.
And so in this case, it's very much like topic
modeling.
It is an unsupervised method.
And we can, moreover, kind of have a description
of those typical conditions or phenotypes
we are looking for.
So for example here, we have lupus.
And we're finding, again, in a very unsupervised
fashion, that anti-malarial are a medication
class that actually makes sense for lupus.
And for the non-clinicians out there, actually,
that's correct.
Anti-malarial are a way of treating lupus.
Another type of application which is really,
really big in health care, but is becoming
really big also on social media type of situations
is predictive analytics.
So the question here is, can we use text--
either text which involves a patient or in
this case, in this example that I'm giving,
text that are written by individuals on reddit.
And can I predict whether something is likely
to happen, or they're likely to behave in
a certain fashion.
So in this example, we are interested in mental
health.
And the authors are looking at subreddit that
have people talking about their depression.
And then they want to know within six months,
are they actually now moving on to another
type of subreddit which is more about suicide
watch.
And so the question here is, can I predict
that someone is going to start ideating about
suicide?
And it turns out that there are very specific
linguistic indicators that can help us predict
who is going to be likely to move on from
the mental health type of subreddit to the
suicide watch type of subreddit.
You can imagine, there's a lot of interesting
applications that can come out of this work.
But what's nice is that there's these cues
that come from the syntax, or from the type
of words that are being used by people, where
we can actually predict what's going to happen
in their behavior in an online community.
Similarly, in the clinical world, we can,
again, try to predict adverse outcomes.
So here, this is an example of a predictive
model that looks at progression of chronic
kidney disease.
And what's interesting here is that, because
we're in the clinical world, we want to be
able to predict, but we also want to be able
to interpret some of our learned rules.
And so the type of methods that are used here
are, again, unsupervised, and are basically
learning topics together with a kind of a
temporal model, which is a common filter in
this case.
But primarily for NLP purposes, the
point is that we can learn topics of words
that occur in clinical notes that are going
to be more or less predictive or increasing
risks for progression-- those are the orange/red
topics in here-- and the ones that are going
to have a productive effect on patients.
And so that's, again, useful, because we can
go further, generate hypotheses, and work
further with clinicians on these questions.
I spent a lot of time on those applications.
But I think it's useful.
And again, there's many, many others.
It's just useful, hopefully, for you-- and
it's definitely helpful for me in my research--
to think very widely about all the different
types of texts as data or seasoned knowledge
versus the various types of tasks we want
to to.
But I want to now focus on, well, OK, so we
know that there are lots of applications to
natural language processing, but why is it
so hard?
And more specifically, why can't I just use
regular expressions?
Regular expressions are just like models of
what I expect a set of string or characters
is going to look like, and it's going to help
me search for a particular type of information
on a large collection of text, for example.
Why do I need more complex models of language?
Well, the first problem is that language is
ambiguous.
And it's ambiguous at all linguistic levels.
And for those interested in what I mean by
linguistic levels, morphology, lexical levels
in texts, discourse and pragmatics are all
interesting levels to think about.
And here are some of the examples that are
the classic examples.
These examples are taken actually taken from
the excellent, excellent course from Chris
Manning at Stanford on Natural Language Processing.
And so here is one where there's definitely
some syntax you can [INAUDIBLE].
Boy paralyzed after tumor fights back to gain
black belt.
Same for this other headline in the news,
"San Jose Cops Kill Man with a Knife."
So where is the ambiguity here?
Well, are we saying who had the knife, basically?
Are we saying that the cops had a knife, and
that's how they killed the man?
Are we saying that the cops killed a man who
had a knife?
And so that type of ambiguity is called PP
attachment ambiguity.
We don't know if we were to build a syntactic
parse for that sentence, we don't know where
we should attach that phrase "with knife."
Should we attach it to the noun phrase, "man?"
or should we attach it to the noun phrase,
"San Jose cops?"
It's actually ambiguous.
We do not know.
We do know, maybe, as humans when we read
it, because maybe there is some more likely
scenario.
But it's still ambiguous.
There could be a scenario where the cops are
killing the man with a knife.
Sorry, that was ambiguous, too.
They are killing a man, and they're using
a knife to kill him.
Some of our more clinical examples, where
ambiguity creeps in are very lexical for us
in clinical texts.
This is an
actual example from a social history of a
patient, and this patient's history-- CA in
mother, breast CA.
And so we have here a term, which is CA, which
happens to be an abbreviation.
And those type of abbreviations are usually
fairly ambiguous.
In the first occurrence of CA, we mean California.
In the second one, we mean cancer, and in
particular, breast cancer.
So how do we build a language model that can
help us disambiguate between these cases?
Moreover there is other senses to this type
of text, to this type of terms.
For example, CA also means calcium.
So this lexical ambiguity is quite difficult.
The other challenge with language is the one
of variability.
And again, it happens at all linguistic levels.
Another way to think of it is that there's
a high paraphrasing power in language.
And it's a good thing, actually, because as
humans, we want to have ability to create
new ways of saying new things, but also old
things.
There usually are some reasons to why you
would say a sentence one way or another.
But for the sake of computing, we want to
be able to identify that maybe different forms
of a term actually refer to the same concept,
like on the example on the left.
Diabetes mellitus 2, diabetes, T2 DM-- all
of these three and many others-- how can I
build a model that recognizes that these guys
are all talking about type 2 diabetes?
And note that I put diabetes here as an example.
And that's actually ambiguous.
Are we talking about type 1 or type 2 diabetes?
And so maybe there's some additional reasoning
that would tell me that in my corpus, really
when I see diabetes, I mean type 2 diabetes.
And I'm able to map or normalize all of these
forms to a single concept.
And so that's an example of variability from
the lexical standpoint.
But there is, obviously, a lot of variability
in syntactically.
John loves Mary.
Mary is loved by John.
The man who is named John loves Mary.
All these things mean the same thing.
They're paraphrases of each other, and are,
nevertheless, conveyed with different syntactic
structures.
It's interesting to think further about the
lexical ambiguity, and really go back to that
question about diabetes.
Do we mean diabetes type 2 in general?
So the context is really helpful in these
things.
And as a matter of fact, a lot of the computational
methods are incorporating context to determine
this type of language models.
And so I thought I would show you a very simple
visualization of what we mean by context.
So here we have two online health communities.
One is the same Autism Spectrum Disorder discussion
forum that I mentioned earlier.
And the other one is a general parenting discussion
forum.
And again, we built a representation of all
the terms that are being mentioned
in those forums.
And we do some normalization, as much as we
can, but we also do then try to look for co-occurrence
patterns.
And so two terms are going to happen, in this
network, an edge between them if they co-occur
together more often than they do not.
And so why am I putting these two networks
here?
Those are networks centered, actually, on
a single node-- on the node "drug" here.
And similarly here on the ASD on your left,
about the node "drug" but as it is mentioned
in the autism communities.
And so what do we see?
Well, it's two very, very different networks.
And clearly, you can say a lot about, even
though they are exactly the same terms, that
they mean completely different things in different
contexts.
And so in the general parenting forum, "drug"
is typically meant as an illicit or illegal
drug, or a problematic drug like alcohol,
marijuana, substance abuse.
Pharmaceutical company's more about the pharma
type of drug and illicit.
Those are the terms that are found as being
statistically important related to "drug."
In the autism world, clearly, they mean different
types of drugs.
And moreover, all of these drugs are very
representative of the type of treatments that
children on the spectrum are using.
So again, from an NLP standpoint, the interest
here is that, even though there are terms
that have exactly the same lexical information,
they actually mean different things in different
contexts.
And so a lot of the methods that are being
developed nowadays have to do with language
modeling, with trying to represent or encode
what is the meaning of the particular word
through what type of words they occur or co-occur
with.
This is a similar example again.
Same word on both sides means very, very different
things in two types of context.
In general parenting, when parents talk about
language, they mean foul language or maybe
bilingual language.
Whereas in the autism community, language
is all about all of the potential symptoms
related to autism, as well as potential therapies
that have to do with helping with language
difficulties.
The last challenge that I will focus on through
very simple examples is the fact that language
is vague.
And another way to think about it is that
maybe we need to reason about language.
And like for the ambiguity and the variability
challenges, it's present at all lexical levels.
So there's three types of example that I want
to focus on.
The first one is one that we see quite a lot
in the clinical world.
This is two sentences-- MI three weeks ago,
MI three days ago.
So what's the question here?
First of all, we need to recognize that MI
means of myocardial infarct in this case.
That's fine.
That's a lexical ambiguity or paraphrasing
[INAUDIBLE] question.
But here, I want to focus on that temporal
expression here, which is three weeks ago.
And here it says three days
ago.
If we want to actually reason over this information,
and if we want to understand or represent
the meaning of those occurrences, we need
to understand that first of all, this is a
temporal expression.
And moreover, it is about that clinical event
which was a myocardial infarct.
The last thing you'd want to do, then, is
to say, well, OK, so if we were to establish
a timeline of events of the patient, then
I would use a time at which the note was written,
and I would go three weeks in the past, and
put the myocardial infarct at that time.
That would be a sensible thing to do automatically.
It turns out that in the clinical world, that's
not always correct.
That's not always the right thing to do.
I mean, it is the right thing to do, but it's
more complex than that.
And so what's going on?
Well, we can actually find that when someone
says, "MI three days ago," in fact, the person
said three days ago.
They really meant that it happened three days
ago.
But when a clinician says three weeks ago,
it could be three weeks ago-- 21 days ago.
But it could be 20 days ago, or 19 days ago,
or something like that.
And it sounds like it's not an important problem.
It actually is quite an important problem
for two reasons.
One is that it's not always the case that
this type of temporal information is available
in the structured part of the electronic health
record.
We really want to rely on the notes, because
the notes are often talking about events that
did not happen in the current institution,
or for various reasons.
The second one is, if we want to study temporal
or time-related phenomena like adverse drug
reactions or prediction of particular events,
we really want to have the timeline down correctly.
And so how do we know that when someone says
"three weeks ago," that really meant 21 days
plus or minus four days, whereas when someone
says "three days ago," that really means three
days ago?
We need some reasoning here.
Or at least we need a way to encode this type
of uncertainty about the language.
Speaking of uncertainty, the next example
is interesting as well.
And that's something that happens, actually,
very often in the clinical and in the health
domain.
So when I say, "Paul thinks that John loves
Mary," there are a few things that are happening
from a linguistic standpoint.
First is that there is the fact that says
that John loves Mary.
And now, what can we say about that fact?
Is it true?
Or is it untrue?
What do we know exactly?
We actually do not know whether that fact
is true.
But we know that a third person thinks that
that fact is true.
Similarly, this type of pragmatic things creep
up even in clinical NLP.
When someone says, "Patient denies smoking,"
that's typically pharma's "Patient does not
smoke."
But really, when we think about it, it really
means, "I do not know whether the patient
smokes or not, but I'm going to encode it,
and I'm going to represent it by saying the
patient denies it."
It's something to think about when we do this
type of information extraction and reasoning.
In the health domain, that comes quite often.
You can imagine if a patient says, write a
question online or searches for some symptoms
somewhere, or writes to their peers, and they
often would say, "I think this is happening."
And there's a lot of uncertainty about all
of these phenomena that they're discussing.
And so the last thing we would want to do
as NLP practitioners would be to extract this
information and just say, look, it says, "John
loves Mary."
I'm going to just extract that fact as being
true, and ignore the other part of the sentence.
So taking into account this uncertainty of
language is very interesting.
The final type of reasoning that's needed,
I think, is illustrated well by that tweet
example, where this person says that they
just ate a bowl of Xanax for breakfast.
It's true it's a well-formed sentence-- which,
by the way, does not happen often on Twitter,
so that's good.
Even the medication is well written in here,
so there's no problem of identifying that
Xanax means Xanax.
The question is, did this person actually
eat a bowl of Xanax for breakfast?
Probably not.
And so is it sarcasm?
Is it humor?
Or did this person actually mean that they
didn't eat a whole bowl of it, but maybe they
ate a lot of Xanax?
And maybe we would want to pay attention to
that type of signal when doing monitoring
of Twitter.
We want to be able to build models that can
recognize that there's something uncertain
about this information.
So approaches to health NLP-- there are actually
many, many different approaches out there.
And I made kind of like an editorial choice
in focusing on two types of methods.
And I'll talk about a third one in the current
developments, but keep in mind, again, I'm
just giving you an overview.
And I definitely suggest that if you're interested
in the field of natural language processing
in the health domain, there are wonderful
classes online and tutorials.
And I'm happy to, if you want to get in touch
with me, to point you to some of them.
So a task for which a lot of methods have
been designed over time in clinical texts
and clinical NLP is one of information extraction.
So the task is, if I have a sentence like
this one, "Patient should come back if severe
facial rash occurs," I want to be able to
do some what's called "named entity recognition,"
meaning that I recognize that "facial rash"
is a disorder.
It's a type of problem that can happen to
the patient.
Not only that, it's a particular concept in
a terminology.
In this case, I'm showing you a concept in
the UMLS, the Unified Medical Language System,
which is a really large terminology.
And maybe I'd like to extract other modifiers
about these particular disorders.
So in this case, maybe I would want to identify
that "severe" is an
important modifier here.
And the "if" here is also, as you can imagine,
quite important, and is indicating that this
is a conditional type of disorder.
In other words, the patient actually does
not have a facial rash, but the facial rash
is discussed, nevertheless, in the context
of this particular patient.
So what other type of modifiers have been
thought about?
Many, many different ones.
This is an example of a set of modifiers for
disorders.
We would want it normalized to a terminology.
We would want to be able to identify negation,
who the subject of that disorder is, who is
the disorder attributed to is another way
to think about it.
Is there uncertainty?
Is there some sort of progression or course
mentioned about that disorder?
What is the severity of the disorder?
Is it conditional, like in the example earlier?
Or is it actually not a disorder, like in
this example, when we say, "The patient goes
to the HIV clinic."
Really, it says "HIV," and HIV is a disorder,
but HIV clinic is really an identity recognition
we would want to pay attention to.
And if there is a particular body location
that's affected by the disorder, like facial
rash, facial is actually part of the important
body location we would want to extract here.
So there's been a lot of work in natural language
processing to kind of define this type of
schemas to figure out what it is that we want
to extract in clinical texts like this one.
That's one type of work.
And typically, this is done through lots of
annotations of text.
And there's a whole field of research about
how to do these annotations in a way that
is correct, in ways that we can trust the
type of annotation, that we found that the
schemas are generic enough, and can be applied
to many different types of information extraction
systems.
And then, of course, we want to be able to
build methods that are going to actually use
the schema, and then go to a new type of text,
and identify those named entities being mentioned,
along with all of these modifiers.
This is a really, really large field of research
in clinical NLP.
And so I just am giving here literally three
examples of famous papers here on this domain.
But there are many, many more.
The examples I'm giving here is from the takes
from the cTAKES system, which is actually
open source.
And you can try, if you have any clinical
texts.
And the reason I like it is it kind of shows
you all of the different part of the pipeline
that the system goes through in order to do
this named entity recognition.
So there is a sentence here that says, "Family
history," FX is an abbreviation for family
history, "of obesity, but no family history
of coronary artery disease."
So the first question is, how do we talk nice?
And this, I believe in the text framing lecture,
you guys had some discussion of that.
We want to then identify the part of speech
of all of those different sentences, the different
words in the
sentences, and maybe do what's called a shallow
parsing, meaning we would identify not the
whole syntactic structure of the sentence,
but rather what are the primary noun phrases.
So a noun phrase would be a set of words that
together refer to a noun, a [INAUDIBLE] noun.
And from there, we would then go and look
for particular noun phrases that can be mapped
to a terminology, like here.
So obesity is found, and coronary artery disease
is found.
But also coronary artery, and artery, and
diseases.
And all of those are potential named entities
we would want to identify.
Furthermore, the status for obesity is that
it's a family history, as opposed to that
patient has obesity, and it's not negated.
So nowadays, I think that the state of the
art type of named entity recognition systems
are using sequence labellers.
And again, [INAUDIBLE] kind of mentioned it,
and so I thought I would move on from there.
But you can see what I mean here by sequence
label, where I'm able to go through each of
these terms, each of these words, and I'm
slowly building up these particular term,
"coronary artery disease," by saying that
this is the beginning of my entity, and I'm
going to keep in my sequence of terms until
I feel like it doesn't belong to the named
entity anymore.
You've heard me refer to terminologies quite
a lot.
And this is outside the scope of this lecture,
but you realize, I hope, that we are relying
heavily in this type of clinical task on lexicons,
or terminologies, or ontologies.
And one huge challenge is, how do we ensure
that the lexicon actually captures the language
of the corpus under study?
The UMLS is very large, but it's also quite
specific, for example, to clinical and technical
type of language.
And so now, when we are dealing working in
online health communities or on Twitter, we
need to figure out ways to either augment
or shelter the UMLS.
And NLP can help for this as well.
Another type of approach that's been really
helpful and I've mentioned is one of probabilistic
topic model.
And I would like to refer you for this of
all the work of David Blei, and all of the
people who worked on this for the past 10
plus years.
The idea here is a very different approach
to clinical named entity recognition, and
is looking at in ways completely unsupervised,
and is trying to find patterns of text, and
in particular, is trying to identify clusters
of words that tend to co-occur quite often
with each other, such that the documents that
they appear on are considered to be a probabilistic
mixture of those clusters or topics.
And so you can add the output of your topic
modeling, or in this case, latent Dirichlet
allocation, you can identify that all of these
different words together are very likely to
be part of that topic.
And moreover, we could think of that topic,
as humans, as being about genetics, or evolution,
or disease in particular for that example.
I have not talked at all about evaluation.
But this is something that people think a
lot about in health natural language processing.
There's a lot of task-based evaluation.
So when we do progression of disease, we think
of
task-based evaluation as did I predict who
is going to progress accurately?
And that's fine.
But when we think about the core NLP methods,
we do usually need gold-standard annotations
to do some sort of validation, or internal
validation, or intrinsic evaluation of the
core NLP methods.
And again, it's the whole topic.
So I'm not touching on it, but I'm mentioning
it here.
So I want to finish with the current developments
in health NLP and NLP research.
And this is a very exciting type of research
that is happening for the past less than five
years, actually, and which is the event of
neural nets in the world of linguistics.
And so I felt like I couldn't really point
you to very specific papers.
But if you are interested in the context of
deep learning and natural language processing,
Richard Socher at Stanford has an excellent
class.
And all material is given online.
So I suggest that you go and either read,
or even try to do the homework.
But I thought that basically, there's four
areas that are very interesting, I think,
from an NLP standpoint as far as new areas
of work.
One is a better or improved language model.
We know already that we need a good contextual
representation of what words are.
And now, through neural nets, we have better
contextual representations, not only of the
words, but what the sequence of the words,
or even sequences of characters, represent.
And that has been shown to be extremely powerful.
We have better sequenced models.
And so remember that named entity recognition
task, where we're looking for a sequence of
words that together define a medical term,
for instance, recurrent neural nets, either
on words or on characters, are very exciting,
because it can capture rich, long-distance
dependencies in text, which was not possible
with different models, like CRF, for example.
Finally, there is really interesting work
in learning models for mixed modalities.
So what do I mean by mixed modality?
Things like text plus images, text plus laboratory
tests, et cetera.
And so we've had some example in the applications,
where we know that by incorporating all this
metadata, if you want, about a patient, or
about an individual online, we can actually
predict better or understand better what a
person is talking about, or what a doctor
is talking about with respect to a patient.
And finally, there is interesting new type
of machine learning.
I'm thinking about a adversarial neural nets
and reinforcement learning, in particular,
that are starting to show some very useful
progress in NLP.
So again, I'm not pointing you to any specific
papers.
But if you're interested, there are some classes
online for you to look at.
So I want to conclude by telling you that
language has pervasive.
It's hard to process automatically.
And sometimes, it's also hard for humans.
But that's because there is ambiguity.
There is variability and vagueness.
But there is much progress that has been done.
And I'll finish by saying that this is an
active field of research, both
in terms of the core NLP methods that are
being developed, but also in ways of thinking
of how to leverage texts in general for biomedical
knowledge discovery, characterizing diseases
and behavior, improving care, et cetera.
So with that, I'll stop.
And hopefully, there is enough time for questions.
Thank you, Dr. Elhadad for a great talk and
overview on NLP and the medical and health
domains.
So we have one question for you from the audience.
This first question is regarding privacy issues.
And so a lot of the examples that you gave
are from social media like reddit and other
areas where you might be monitoring forums
and such.
Can you address how issues related to privacy
and potentially de-identification are addressed
in this type of work?
Obviously, that has applications also, more
specifically when you're monitoring clinical
records.
But if you could touch broadly on that, that
would be appreciated.
Great, yes, that's a great question.
And you're right, I didn't talk about this.
I gave you an overview of different papers
out there.
And everyone has their own [INAUDIBLE] of
their own institution that usually makes sure
that the methods are being respectful of the
participants, in this case, the people who
write those texts, or the people about which
these texts are written.
So when it comes to online communities and
social media, most of the papers I've seen
deal with publicly available data sets and
text corpora.
So for example, this breast cancer data set
that I mentioned very early on is completely
available online.
Twitter is available if you don't pay attention
to private messages, et cetera.
There are some questions about how would you--
say you go and crawl in the entirety of an
online health community.
How do you go about distributing these data?
As researchers, we do not have the right to
distribute it.
We need to have, somehow, the agreement of
the people who created and are monitoring
these data.
And so people have been looking a lot into
how to de-indentify texts.
And there are some, both commercial and research,
identifiers out there.
And it turns out it's a very institution-specific
type of thing, where some institutions are
OK with letting you distribute your data if
you de-identified it, and others are not.
There are de-identified clinical corpora out
there.
[? Minick ?] is one of them.
And there are publicly available online health
communities out there.
Great, so our second question is actually
about evaluation.
What is the typical error rate in interpreting
these texts?
As you apply actually language processing
techniques, obviously, it's not necessarily
perfect.
And as you pointed out, there is a lot of
inherent vagueness to the texts.
So even humans are not necessarily perfect.
But can you discuss what the typical error
rate might be?
And are there any examples where any misinterpretations
have actually led to bad decisions?
OK, so I feel like there are kind of two questions--
unintended consequences of recognition of
something and what is the typical error rate.
It's hard to say what typical is.
If you think of a named entity recognition
system, it's typically built with a terminology
in mind for a particular type of text.
And so if I type UMLS and cTAKES and apply
it to-- or MetaMap or MedLEE-- and apply it
to an autism community, I might find that
I have an error rate of, say, 40% in F-measure.
But if I were to do exactly the same, and
apply it to clinical notes, I would have an
error rate of 85 F-measure.
So it's difficult to say, without thinking
of the task, the corpus, and the terminologies,
for example, how accurate typically an named
entity recognition system is.
And what this is pointing at is that there's
not a whole lot of benchmarking in health
NLP.
That's something that the community is working
on heavily.
So there have been, for the past few years,
data sets that have been deidentified in the
case of clinical texts where gold-standard
annotations are provided for people to share.
And there are challenges that many different
research groups try different methods.
But everyone agrees to use the same evaluation
metrics on the same benchmark annotations
and texts.
And we can then compare and understand which
methods work better than another.
I would say, though, that we're probably not
as far ahead as we could be compared to other
domains of NLP and other areas of machine
learning, in part because of those privacy
issues, for sure.
Great, so we're actually at 10 o'clock now.
So being mindful of the time, thank you again
so much for giving this talk.
And we'll close it here.
Happy holidays, everyone.
We will be back in January, 2017, with the
next set of talks.
Thank you, and bye, everyone.